hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played between world
chess champion Magnus Carlsen and my
club Brancato
and I was played yesterday in New York
it was a simultaneous exhibition the
exhibition took place in the Rockefeller
Plaza on the 65th floor it's called the
Rainbow Room we do have a couple of
photos from there about Michel Brancato
as you can see on his Twitter handle
here he's a top-level Smash Bros player
so there we have it let's see let's see
if Michael can smash this bro and also
we do have a couple of nice photos there
we have it there's Michael alongside
some other people and some other
contenders there's a nice photo of him
shaking hands with magnus carlsen after
after the game was over obviously and
here we have a nice photo of the two of
them together not not that difficult to
to decide on who sponsored event but
yeah interesting thing about the this
event I was also invited to to join as a
guest not perhaps I could even play but
I wasn't all that much interested in
playing but I would have liked like to
attend but I had some personal matters
to attend to so I will definitely try to
try to you know attend the next event of
this this type I was invited by Richard
Khan the organizer and I met the
gentleman in London he gave me a copy of
his book the earthbound parent and also
introduced me to Woody Harrelson
so quite quite the guy but yeah that
being said really hoping to catch the
next event let's get straight into the
game Carson has the white pieces as the
one who holds the simultaneous
exhibition always has the white pieces
that's the the rule otherwise you could
have that you know a whole scenario for
example when that rich person offered
the last grand Capablanca to play them
both in a simultaneous exhibition and
then he would just play a couple Don
Kaas move to Alaska and Oscar's move to
cabal Wonka I think there was an
illusionist that also created created
such an event with grandmasters but okay
that's a that's a different story
the four by Carlson we have nice
six we have Bishop to g5 this is the
Trump off ski attack and already I've
seen in the tweet I will put a link to
his original tweet in the description
below so you can check it out
he says that he was planning to go for
an Indian game but the Bishop g5 move
already surprised him and he didn't know
what to do here he was not aware of the
existence of the Trump or ski so you
played east six with nice to d2 by
crossing d5 and now comes a III just a
preparing to develop the LightSquared
bishop we have Knight B to d7 Knight G
to F 3 and we have Bishop to d6 both
players are now preparing to Castle
Bishop to d3 by Carlsen we have castles
castles by both players and now h6
asking do you want to capture on on f6
or go back with the bishop Carlsen
retreats and here we have B 6 and here
black is doing perfectly fine he's ready
to play Bishop e7 he's ready to develop
the rook to c8 for example he's ready to
push c5 the rock is coming to it you
know it's a quite quite quite a nice
position we have C 4 by Carlsen Bishop
to b7 as planned and now Crossan takes
this opportunity he doesn't want black
to play d chapters on c4 which would
free blacks light square bishop
so here Carlsen place C captures on d5
and here eat after Sunday 5 is played
you might think it's it'd be a better
idea to capture for example with the
bishop you cannot capture with the night
the knight is pinned but if you capture
with the bishop yes now your bishop is
free but now this losses to a very
simple tactic just eat for after the
light squared bishop moves e5 wins the
game so here after C captures on d5 we
have it captures on d5 and now Queen te
2 develops the queen cross and connect
rooks and also takes control of the a6
square we have c5 by black as planned or
you know standard ideas one might one
might also use for example in the
Queen's Queens gambit declined and now
bush up to a six by cross and he wants
to trade the light square bishop and
also infiltrate the Queen side with his
Queen rook to b8
defending and now comes and Bishop
captures rook captures and now comes F
or here D captures on e4 was played I'm
a slightly better move would have been
CT after Sunday for now if
is not a threat due to rook to e8 and
then black wins the other pawn as well
but okay
we have D captures on e4 now comes
Knight captures any nice captures on e4
and now rook to a rook to e8 painting
Carlson's night but it's not a really
big problem Carlsen can simply untangle
by Knight captures this would come with
check but Carson goes for a different
plan here Carlsen plays Queen to a6 and
now black has some problems his rook is
under attack on b7 and also the bishop
is under attack on d6
and there is no easy way to defend
against both threats the best course of
action here for black would be to just
capture on e for Allah white to grab the
rook so white would have to win the
exchange and then go g5 after Bishop
here captures captures and now capture
on d4 and at least for the exchange
black would have a past the D pawn so
maybe he could you know create some
poison there but okay after Queen to a6
we have Queen to c7 now defending the
rook and the bishop but it's you know
quite a quite an often problem one might
encounter in chess where one piece gets
overwhelmed in defending both pieces so
the Queen cannot defend both the rook
and the bishop here so Carson now simply
eliminates the defender of the rook
which is the Queen I mean just a for
forces her to move Knight captures and
e6 the Queen now has to move Queen
captures and Queen captures and b7
Carlsen now grabs an entire look we have
a five black still has some hopes of
perhaps trapping Carlson's Queen in some
crazy scenario but it's you know mostly
mostly a crazy scenario so rook everyone
we have Ruby rook to b8 attacking the
Queen Queen to a6 preparing to bring
back the Queen into the game and now
just see capture some d4 and okay black
now has a past deep own but down a hold
on a rook not really not really
something to look forward to but also
here there's this problem of this
diagonal push up to g3 by cross and
attacks the Queen and also the rook on
b8 we have Queen to b4 now and rook
captures better captures on b8 and now
you could capture but then just Queen
see it check picks up the night here so
why doesn't even bother to recapture the
bishop
Knight to c5 is played attacking call
since
Queen we have Queen to c2 check King
moves and now Queen to f5 check black
moves back we have came to h8 and now
Bishop to e5 attacking the knight but
also the pawn on d4 we have 97 defending
the knight also pressuring the bishop
but just Bishop captures on before we
have Queen to d6 here and here cross and
just played rook to c1 and it was in
this position that Michael Brancato
professional smash bro player decided to
resign in the game so he was not he was
not able to smash this particular bro
but you know it's playing against the
world champion it's very very highly
unlikely that you will win when or even
draw the game
here black hole obviously resigns he's
down down to looks not just one so it
would be it would be pointless to
continue here
checkmate it's the follow soon so yeah
it was at move 27 coffin play drew Casey
one that Michael Brancato decided to
resign in the game and here we also have
proof that it actually happened there
you have it the score sheet there's
everything there move 27 rook a to C 1 1
to 0 it's not signed but I guess I guess
maybe the photo was taken before cross
and sign it or maybe maybe he doesn't
sign the score sheets at the
simultaneous exhibition so it's it's
hard to say but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it it's not not the
most difficult game the world champion
ever had to play but you know I thought
it was a nice opportunity to bring chest
closer to to another community in this
case the gaming community so you know I
thought if at least a few players from
the gaming community see see this and
maybe take up chess you know it's it's
were worked in a while swim that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it
congratulations to Michael Brancato for
lasting an entire 27 moves against the
world chess champion Magnus Carlsen I
would like to thank Bradford I chipped a
Thomas smiley Roger Rodman berry
McMurray doc and John Edwardson
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
video so you're think all for watching
and I will see you soon definitely
continuing the Capablanca saga we are
about to check out the third
game between Capablanca and Lasker it
will be really really amazing thank you
all and I'll see you soon